Oh Oh this is our favor no no it's fine
look we'll just make an agreement we're
not gonna be stupid the whole time hey
what's going on bro hey just you tell me
if you see anything weird yeah this
trash can seems normal
I believe you some some bottles here
actually you know I got stuck on this
trash can as that is hammer this one's
moving I'm pretty sure this one's Wade
cares cares don't move that's just
science oh no you can't explain that to
see something this rare in our life Bob
this is incredible
all right so which one are you stuck on
the front of the car he probably is he's
already so Loki Loki I'm afraid it's
gonna be too Loki I just hope we get
some good moments out of it you know
yeah I hope there's some good bits oh I
had a connection bro don't please I had
a connection issue I am continuing to
have connection issues sure connection
is
are you moving your brain via I can't I
can neither confirm nor deny thank you
for your your graciousness
no no they let me go spot when I was
your card you were stubborn cold [ __ ]
out of you you stupid cone yeah you can
[Music]
someone really thought our jokes were
[Laughter]
feel like I just have a better chance if
I just stay out in the open so that's
what I'll do how do you do the taunts f3
are you outside I'm still inside I I
decided to hide in the open because I
didn't think that my my skill set was
adequate enough to actually hide your in
these rooms but I don't know what the
[ __ ] was that
don't leave welcome to my office I
wasn't like this waited cuz I wasn't
like all right no mark if you aim the
right way I think you could line up your
stripes yeah I'm trying to it's very
finicky it doesn't want to rotate quite
right it's very picky right there okay
I'm locked look at you
see wait no that's what hole wait wait
wait wait turn around turn around real
quick turn around face away me direction
wait oh [ __ ] me yes yes I mean not for
the [ __ ] he's having trouble in my
brain I went how he's having trouble
every alt f4 weight is very popular in
Amsterdam hookers
he's a watermelon we all know how the
Dutch love everywhere okay well every
single step I take it's a connection
problem I don't know what's going on
guys I'm having trouble the game the
game is protecting you from yourself
no probably but that's not okay I am
floating above my body oh my god there's
a door here I've got a hell of a spot
here definitely gonna win okay
I can't do anything right no that's
probably wait no wait yes coming up mark
now it's real good guys
you're away how many times did you steal
my joke on mark Julie was my job
you recited it so much you've made it
your joke in your mind one my one that
was like that I said you know what my
favorite joke is look go pulling a mask
off and then you started doing it and
though I was already doing it you're
like hey Wayde my favorite thing that
you do is the joke hey ice yeah you do
raise the audience watching weren't
there maybe and I wasn't there so this
isn't about you
this isn't about Bob wait Bob you can
clean this up in on this amazing action
[Laughter]
I will slice you in half magic ball that
didn't sound good all right well does
that mean that I might be able to give
you a run for your money brown how about
that Brown I am also brown slightly
rusted so are you a saw blade the saw
blades
maybe I wasn't that one I'm not even
anywhere near you guys underneath the
trolley that's what I was that was my
hilarious joke it was never yours you're
not mine either
fellers all right way everyone sucks
equally Wow you just put your ass out in
the open where I can shoot it oh that's
you you're a change of heart don't think
I'm gonna come to the London show
anymore no you are gonna be there so you
can settle this for we're both gonna do
the joke exactly you're gonna look at
both of us do the joke over and over and
you can't until you can tell who's been
doing it longer yeah we just kick
everybody else that's in the middle you
ain't know again are your prop hunting
skills as good as your jokes yes and
they're amazing so they're won that
argument I thought I was having a
connection
[Laughter]
I mean I shot and then I wasn't sure so
I shot something hang on there's an orb
got 50 health points awesome why do you
get good things
I can't move I've got connection issues
all right I've got extra health and I
can't move so I'm just gonna start
shooting things beyond your team I swear
that doesn't sound fair at all clear
wait clear wait this is March and clear
all right Martin - Bob no Bob how could
you betray me with identifying exactly
I am I'm sorry Bob I was told to breach
it clear I do not what breaching and
clearing is hired by breaching with my
stays clear you're an idiot
that does check out that story checks
[Music]
it's no one's joke it's a terrible joke
it's not it's hilarious every time a
spectator this mark we need a hint all
right I'm a cinder ball sorry I bet you
one cinder block you can't find mark
that ball looks really enticing Bob I
just want to see this we're gonna I'm
gonna give another chance is this it's
just like your cat your sales counter
hey yeah what do you got how much is one
of these we've got
[Applause]
how about can I do one of those is it a
buy one get one I'm fine thank you don't
worry jack we're not even playing the
game okay cuz Marlene II think you're
making a mess my my store what are you
doing we're giving you things to sell us
take these things take these things
child can we land a Cohen on his head
try then we can still [ __ ] just like sky
William I've got a follow-up to this
unbelievably funny idea all right I'm
ready for this if it doesn't I'll shoot
him right in the face okay okay ha it
didn't work all right let's tone it down
there mr. cone man all right time to get
serious now that the [ __ ] went away
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah yeah I think I agree go in sender
brick all right here you go
that's oh I thought I was like you dust
like colloquialism for basketball I
thought I thought where I was being you
know what the brick sorry but this no
you know just you're making it what
something in me can you still do the
exploit where you can climb with with
things infinitely if you stand on them
[Music]
for you from your prison of mark are we
taking a bath together right now I am
not in the bath but I'll say yes
[Music]